[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen bei
Larissa bekämpft den Fachkräftemangel
ich bin Larissa und ich bekämpfe den
Fachkräftemangel mit der ein oder andere
von euch vielleicht schon mal gehört hat
gibt es in Deutschland ein eklatant
großen Mangel und zwar von Fachkräften
ich spreche nämlich von den sogenannten
Fachkräfte Mangel das ist ein Mangel für
Fachkräften und dagegen werde ich jetzt
angehen und ihr könnt es auch los geht's
[Musik]
ich bin hier im
Seniorenstift Sankt Hubertus
ich möchte euch heute den Beruf zeigen
der wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig
ist ich würde sagen noch wichtiger als
Nagelstudio und Shisha Bar zusammen
wirklich es klingt unmöglich aber es ist
die Wahrheit Altenpflege das bedeutet im
Umkehrschluss die Pflege von alten
es gibt nämlich immer mehr alte Leute
das ist mittlerweile voll der Trend oh
meine Güte hier sitzt du schon wieder
drei neue ich schwöre die saßen vorhin
noch nicht da und das ist das Schlimme
es reicht ihn nicht dass sie alt sind
nein sie wollen noch
älter werden und Sie werden das auch ja
weil die Ärzte immer besser werden und
die Medizin dies das ist ein
Teufelskreis und die Heime Sequent
teilweise wirklich über von diesen
runzeligen gestalten ehrlich gesagt das
erinnert mich ein bisschen so an dieser
einen Netflix Serie wisst ihr wie
schnell die eine wo die Zombies die Welt
übernehmen
wirklich was passiert ich weiß nicht
aber alte Leute machen mir irgendwie
Angst weil sie sind nicht mehr so
ja sie sind nicht mehr so jung aus wisst
ihr wie schmecken aber zum Glück können
wir sie in Häuser wie dieses hier
sperren es ist wie ein großer
Bushaltestelle nur dass man hier nicht
auf den Bus wartet sondern auf ein
ganzes Licht oder so ich weiß nicht ich
fahre nicht Bus aber auch hier in diesem
Haus muss ich ja leider jemand um sie
kümmern und damit sind wir schon beim
Kasus Knackpunkt es fehlen jetzt schon
200.000 Pflegekräfte krass das ist eine
so so große Zahl aber sie stimmt und da
kommst du Deutsch spielen
schau in diese Augen und sagt ja ich
werde den Pflegekraft
entschuldigung ich möchte nicht
respektieren aber das stimmt nicht mit
den Haaren gibt's
oh du meine Güte die Pflegeversicherung
sie zahlt kein Conditioner und das sind
so in welchem Land wie Deutschland
Skandal
die Ausbildung zur entpflegefachfrau
oder in pflegefachmann das kannst Du
selber entscheiden glaube ich welches
von beiden jedenfalls ist die Ausbildung
drei Jahre und das ist meines Erachtens
nach auch voll gerechtfertigt weil du so
viele Sachen lernst viel mehr als zum
Beispiel ein Arzt ein Arzt da guckt
vielleicht mal so in den Ohr und
verteilt Rezepte aber das bringt den ja
nichts weil viele alte Menschen können
auch fast gar nichts mehr selber machen
geschweige denn ein schaffe den es bei
tiktok leider nein man muss ihnen essen
geben Sie abends im Bett bringen morgens
waschen in den Fernseher anmachen guten
Abend
[Musik]
was guckst du da für Musik
glaub mir das kann nicht gesund sein
schnell ich mach das weg
[Musik]
heute sind man darf sich da auch nicht
vormachen das ist ein Knochenjob also
körperlich es ist vergleichbar wie
Security du musst schon fit sein und
schnell
und Styling und nach Shooting sind die
besten Folgen ich schwöre bringst du mir
noch eine käse-schule mit und Joghurt
aber nicht Kirsche ich hasse Kirsche
also ich weiß nicht ich persönlich
möchte nie so alt werden und ganz
ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob ich es
überhaupt jemals schaffen werde so z.B
52 Jahre alt zu werden das dauert
bestimmt noch ewig aber ja falls ich
doch irgendwann mal alt sein sollte dann
möchte ich natürlich auch dass ich ein
netter junger Mensch um mich kümmert ja
der Pflegeberuf macht richtig glücklich
weil man übernimmt Verantwortung
[Musik]
kann jetzt nicht ich übernehme gerade
Verantwortung
die Arme Oma sie liegt am Boden genau
das passiert wenn man zu wenig
Fachkräfte hat da muss die Politik
unbedingt besser werden
die Arbeit ist sehr abwechslungsreich
ich helfe hier den Omis und Opis
beweglich zu bleiben weil man sagt ja
auch gesunder Körper kranker Geist oder
umgekehrt egal so mit den Armen sind wir
jetzt fertig
als nächstes üben wir twerken
das brauchen Moment tanzen das ist ein
absolutes basic ich mache euch das mal
vorher
schicken lassen
von allen Menschen über 90 sind
dreiviertel pflegebedürftig also drei
von vier die drei hier ich weiß gerade
nicht
schachmatt
man verdient doch ganz okay also das
kommt natürlich darauf an ich sag mal
mehr als ein lieferando-fahrer und
weniger als ein gangster rapper aber man
macht das ja nicht wegen Geld sondern
wegen Menschen weil sie sind wie du und
ich also mach dich zum Pflegefachkraft
bevor du selbst zu alt bist
meine Güte nimmst du etwa Drogen bist du
verrückt wenn sich jemand erwischt
[Musik]
falls ihr kein Topmodel gucken könnt
dann könnt ihr ja hier die Videos
anklicken und schauen was ich da noch so
alles gemacht habe
[Musik]